quel est ce que j'ai acheté très joli
centre de koné
[Musique]
plus technique
sous l année
[Musique]
c'est un moment très important qui a été
organisée par la ville de paris et qui
est là pour compter les personnes qui
sont dans la rue ce n'est pas pour venir
ce soir en aide aux personnes à la rue
c'est pour que les comptes et c'est très
important de savoir combien de personnes
sont dans la rue pour complice après
adapte éventuellement des des procédures
pour aller auprès de soi par des
maraudes sort avec des associations etc
[Musique]
on s'aperçoit aussi que certains sont là
depuis longtemps donc il faut savoir
pourquoi ils sont là on leur poser
quelques questions savoir s'ils sont
depuis longtemps dans la rue savoir
s'ils ont déjà eu un hébergement savoir
si ils ont déjà appelé le 115
s'il 115 a répondu s'il 115 n'a pas
répondu on a beaucoup de femmes
maintenant et d'enfants à la rue et donc
c'est pour mettre un maximum avoir un
maximum de renseignements pour essayer
de sortir le maximum de personnes de la
rue ce qui est pas très facile cette
année c'est la première fois que j'ai la
chance de faire la nuit de la sociale et
solidarité pourra essayer des contes et
légendes est d'avoir le nombre des
régions qui sont dans la rue moi
personnellement je suis ici de 15e et
donc je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
par rapport à l'année dernière donc je
pense que ça les gens qui sont en
situation de rue je pense que ça ça
remonte et je pense de mon point de vue
[Musique]
alors le rôle de chef d'equipe c'est
d'accompagner l'équipe de bénévoles dans
le quartier qu'on nous attribue pour
pouvoir être certaine que les bénévoles
sont le travail qu'on leur demande à
savoir questionner toutes les personnes
qui sont en situation de rue et bien
remplir les questionnaires
[Musique]
mon
alors on commence de façon très générale
par observer la personne
c'est un homme c'était une femme est
ensuite elle est d'accord pour répondre
aux questions
on lui demande son âge on lui demande
d'où elle vient celle un pari ou d'une
autre ville on lui demande pourquoi elle
dort dehors comme en face laquelle est
dans une situation et on affine petit à
petit ça nous permet d'une part de voir
pourquoi elle est là et aussi quelles
peuvent être ses besoins parce qu'on
termine au questionnaire en lui
demandant notamment si elle a des
besoins en termes de suivi social si
elle est suivie par une assistante
sociale par exemple
et si cette personne souhaite fonds le
cas échéant qu'on voulait qu'on fasse
appel à un travailleur social
[Musique]
ça a été une expérience humaine très
très très forte puisque donc en prévu km
et trois heures de marche
on a rencontré six personnes
dont une a accepté de faire accompagner
afin d'avoir un support du service
social demain on se rend compte à quel
point effectivement on a dans paris des
personnes qui sont dans des situations
de précarité avancé
on en avait quatre dans cette portion du
15e arrondissement
l'année dernière on en a compté 6 cette
année je suis du 15e arrondissement je
suis voisins en fête
donc c'est aussi important pour moi de
voir concrètement dans le quartier
comment les choses se passent on n'a pas
forcément l'occasion de faire toutes les
ruses de paris comme ça de façon aussi
méthodique et donc ça permet
effectivement de mieux se rendre compte
de la situation
[Musique]
alors là on va rentrer la mairie - en
tant que chef d'equipe ma responsabilité
c'est de déposer les questionnaires et
de les vérifier avant de les donner à
l'équipe organisatrice est de bien
vérifier que tout a été remplie que rien
n'est est incohérent et et que ces
questions là vont pouvoir être utile est
rentré dans toutes les statistiques que
l'on va ressortir l'intérieur
[Musique]